this answer here that the profile stores
conference name's not keys is wrong we
do store the conference keys however we
store them as string so this answer is
correct the profile stores for
conference keys and strings so because
they're strings we have to convert them
into keys before we can use the key to
load the entity from the datastore the
reason that we use strings for the keys
is that you can't pass actual key
entities around inside JSON so we create
a website version of the key as a string
and this answer is wrong yeah I know it
would be it would be nice just to simply
return the value of the property but
it's not going to work so you can find
the finished code forget conferences to
attend in the lesson 4 folder if you
need a bit of help writing the code so
go take a look if you need to